après deux jours d'entretiens à genève
le conseil otan russie serait une donc
ce matin pour tenter d'avancer sur le
dossier ukrainien les états unis et
leurs alliés européens vont engager ce
mercredi des discussions avec moscou au
siège de l'alliance objectif tenter
désamorcer le reste d'un nouveau conflit
en ukraine pour le moment les russes
n'ont encore fait aucun geste
d'apaisement on revient sur cette
séquence donc très diplomatique avec
vous armelle charrier bonjour armelle
bonjour lisa pourquoi ce rendez-vous à
nouveau aujourd'hui et surtout pour dire
quoi exactement alors en fait c'est vrai
que lorsque l'on dit la russie rencontre
l'otan ce nous semble banal mais en fait
d'abord c'était gelé depuis 2019 les
rencontres de ce type là est ensuite la
russie quand elle rencontre l'otan est
la rencontre ce qu'elle considère être
son ennemi qu alors l'otan il faut le
rappeler c'est pas qu'une alliance
militaire le but final et militaires
mais ça reste une alliance politique à
la base et donc lorsque la russie en ce
moment rencontre l'otan elle rencontre
le versant politique elle rencontre des
ambassadeurs de chaque pays alors
évidemment elle va rencontrer les
américains qu'elle connaît très bien
puisque de toute manière elle discute
avec des américains et les américains
financement largement l'otan c'est eux
qui ont une parole prépondérante mais à
l'otan vous avez quand même les autres
pays vous avez les pays européens vous
avez la turquie qui reste aussi un
partenaire important et donc qu'il a
aussi va écouter discuter entendre ce
qu'elle veut à kehl à entendre vous avez
des pays qui sont treize antirusse comme
la pologne parce qu'il s'en méfie mais
vous avez des pays qui sont davantage
favorable à la russie et donc c'est le
moment pour donner la ligne rouge de
moscou mais directement au sein même de
l'otan dire je ne veux pas que l'ukraine
vous rejoigne il y à un certain nombre
de pays qui sont anciennement des pays
soviétiques et en aucun cas ils ne
doivent rentrer dans l'otan est la seule
chose qu'on sait c'est que les
américains ont essayé de rassurer un
petit peu les russes en leur disant si
jamais en ukraine en mettra pas des
armes offensives
parce que finalement c'est ça ce que
craint vladimir poutine s'est que très
proche de lui on met des capacités l'
attaque militaire alors on voit bien ce
et ses enjeux diplomatiques notamment
est-ce qu'on n'est pas finalement en
train tout ça n'est pas finalement en
train de servir les intérêts de l'otan
au détriment on en parlait hier déjà des
européens oui que l'otan se réveille
finalement et que on retrouve une vraie
logique à cette alliance alors la
situation redonne une logique
effectivement l'alliance militaire
l'otan créée je vous le rappelle pour
défendre les intérêts européens face à
une à l'époque empire soviétique
aujourd'hui la russie se fait depuis ce
attaquante donc on comprend cette
logique là et elle est tout à fait plus
compréhensible que lorsque l'on parle
par exemple de ce qui se peut se passer
en mer de chine en revanche ce que l'on
voit c'est que si l'otan aujourd'hui est
sollicité c'est un peu au détriment des
européens comme vous le disiez elisabeth
et que ça on leur reproche en ce moment
en disant que par exemple dans la sphère
ukrainienne le processus de normandie
avec la france et l'allemagne qui
viennent à discuter avec la russie et
l'ukraine justement il est un peu état
et c'est là où il faut faire attention
parce que les européens ont quand même
aussi un regard est que lorsque l'on
parle de la menace ukrainienne
aujourd'hui lorsque l'on dit que la
russie s'apprête à envahir effectivement
l'ukraine les français par exemple les
européens sont aussi capables d'avoir
des services de renseignement ils sont
aussi capables de se parler en dehors de
la pression américaine et de dire ben
nous on fait pas tout à fait le même
constat il faut savoir quand même que
les américains ont parfois des
stratégies qui nous échappe souvenons
nous ce qui s'est passé lorsqu'il a
fallu parler de la phase yong irak sur
lequel il s'était basée sur un mensonge
et donc à partir du moment donné où les
américains disent c'est quelque chose
qui est à observer et qui nous inquiète
eh bien il faut aussi avoir une lecture
complémentaire qui sera soit la même
soit différente et aujourd'hui quand on
discute avec les diplomates qui discute
avec les ukrainiens élisent les
ukrainiens ne sont pas si inquiet que ça
de voir des exercices russe en masse à
leurs frontières ils ont l'habitude donc
tout ça nécessite effectivement d'avoir
un peu de délicatesse merci beaucoup
armelle pour le décryptage l'éclairage
aussi il rappelle de cet autre point de
vue européen